lala minec tome a es la extracción
quirúrgica de una parte de la vértebra
conocida como la lámina la columna
vertebral o espina dorsal está compuesta
por 24 vértebras cada vértebra tiene dos
láminas que unidas forman el techo del
canal raquídeo la lámina protege la
médula espinal en las regiones del
cuello y de la espalda en la parte
inferior de la espalda donde termina la
médula espinal
la lámina protege el gran racimo de
nervios que se conoce como cauda equina
y las raíces nerviosas arak ideas la
compresión de las raíces nerviosas puede
deberse a los osteofitos producidos por
la artritis las hernias de disco que
comprime en la raíz del nervio o con
menor frecuencia los tumores óseos de
las vértebras la lámina tome a alivio el
dolor de espalda y de las piernas
causado por esta compresión de las
raíces nerviosas al extirpar la lámina
en forma total o parcial esto alivia de
inmediato la presión sobre la raíz
nerviosa ante la presencia de una hernia
de disco por lo general el médico
realizará una discectomía a través de la
cual se elimina directamente la causa de
la compresión la la minec tome a se
puede realizar en las vértebras de la
parte
de la espalda llamadas vértebras
lumbares o bien en las de la zona del
cuello llamadas vértebras cervicales la
micro la mi nieto mía y la
microdisectomía son procedimientos que
se realizan con la ayuda de un
microscopio al llegar al hospital se le
colocará una vía intravenosa y es
posible que se le coloque un catéter en
la vejiga para drenar la orina momentos
antes de la cirugía se le administrara
anestesia general o rachidia la
anestesia raquídea se inyecta dentro de
un saco que rodea la médula espinal y
adormece el área en la que el médico va
a trabajar micro y la administra
anestesia raquídea estará despierto
durante el procedimiento pero no sentirá
nada en la mitad inferior de su cuerpo
la lámina atómica lleva entre una y tres
horas durante el procedimiento se le
colocará en posición decúbito ventral
boca abajo o lateral de costado
el cirujano comenzará a realizando una
pequeña incisión sobre la columna las
pinzas se utilizan para separar la grasa
y los músculos de la lámina con un
taladro especial para huesos
el cirujano cortará la lámina para poder
ver el canal raquídeo y ubicar la causa
de la compresión nerviosa si lo que
causa la compresión es una hernia discal
el médico realizará una discectomía para
retirar la protuberancia del disco para
completar el procedimiento se saturarán
los tejidos profundos y la incisión de
la espalda
después de la cirugía se le trasladará a
la sala de recuperación para
monitorearlo las enfermeras comprobarán
de manera regular sus signos vitales y
la fuerza de la pierna del lado donde se
le realizó la cirugía para asegurarse de
que el nervio no haya sufrido ninguna
lesión grave se le recomendará
levantarse y caminar tan pronto como se
sienta bien si se le insertó un catéter
antes de la cirugía el mismo se le
retirará antes de abandonar al hospital
si la disectomía no presenta
complicaciones es probable que le den de
alta al día siguiente de la intervención
las lamento mías que se realicen por
otros motivos pueden requerir
internamientos más prolongados